let's try to evaluate seven and six
ninths minus three and two-fifths so
like always i like to separate out the
whole number parts from the fractional
parts this is the same thing as
seven
at plus six ninths
minus 3
minus 2 fifths and the reason why i'm
saying minus 3 minus 2 fifths is this is
the same thing as minus 3 plus
2 fifths and so you distribute the
negative sign you're subtracting a 3 and
then you're subtracting the two-fifths
and so now we can worry about the whole
number of parts 7
minus 3 well 7 minus 3 is going to give
us 4
so that's going to give us 4 and then
we're going to have 6 9
minus 2 fifths so let me think about
what 6 9 minus 2 fifths are 6 9 minus 2
fifths well we're going to have to find
a common denominator so this is going to
be the same thing and i think the least
common multiple of nine and five is
going to be 45 literally them multiplied
they have no common factors so it's
going to be over 45 they go from 9 to 45
to multiply by 5 so i'm gonna have to
multiply the numerator by 5. so 6 times
5 is 30 and i'm going to subtract to go
from 5 to 45 i had to multiply by 9
except to multiply the numerator by 9 if
i don't want to change the value so 2
times 9 is 18. and 30 over 30 40 fifths
minus 18 45 is going to be something
over 45 30 minus 18 is 12. so this is if
i if i subtract these two fractions
right over here i get 12
twelve forty fifths so it's four plus
twelve forty-fifths so if we wanted to
write it as a mixed number this is equal
to four and twelve
forty-fifths but we're not done yet we
can simplify this further twelve and
forty-five have common factors they are
both divisible by they're both divisible
by 3.
so we can say that this is actually
they're both divisible by well we can i
think we can divide more after that so
let's see if we divide the numerator by
3 and the denominator by 3
we end up with 4 and 12 divided by 3 is
and 45 divided by 3
45 divided by 3 is 15. 4 and 4 15. and
actually we're done these two can't be
simplified anymore
4 and 4 15.